15h les précieuses copies du bac objet
de toutes les attentions depuis cinq
jours sont là corrigé prête à être rendu
au rectorat de dijon
ces 21 correcteurs grévistes
photographier leurs bordereaux pour
éviter toute contestation
la tension est palpable c'est par amour
du village et par amour des belles
révélations c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
ça parce que le gouvernement ne veut pas
parler avec nous les syndicats nationaux
ces cinq semaines qui demande à être sur
la ba a été reçue ils n'ont pas été
reçus
il veut pas dialoguer avec nous c'est
l'absence de dialogue du gouvernement
ces professeurs sont mobilisés contre la
réforme du lycée depuis novembre ces
derniers jours tous témoignent avoir
reçu des menaces de saisie par huissier
et de sanctions pénales s'ils perdent de
l'argent dans ces affaires là il puisse
faire envoyer des mails de menaces des
mails franchement insultant de la part
du rectorat
donc c'est pas pour nous que la fin
qu'on a fait c'est clairement pour nos
élèves
tout ce qui nous reste à faire c'est
prendre le maximum de protection
possibles rentrer de manière publique et
officielle toutes les copier et comme ça
au moins on m'arrête histoire pour les
soutenir
une foule de près de 200 personnes et
parmi eux des lycéens fraîchement
diplômés on aura nos notes quelques
jours après ça a permis aux professeurs
de se faire entendre
de protester donc je pense que c'est une
bonne chose
à 15h30 vient le moment crucial et
d'honneur pour un baroud d'honneur
près de deux mille copies sont vérifier
et recompter devant la rectrice
ça veut dire qu'ils ont fait leur
travail il n'en demeure pas moins qu'il
y en a qui ont fait beaucoup de travail
il ya pour eux et donc on va réfléchir à
la façon dont on tombe a réagi
les grévistes feront aussi l'objet de
sanctions ils promettent de poursuivre
la mobilisation
sous d'autres formes